[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right people i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message it's
may 10 2022. we're live streaming on
rumble youtube and blaze tv and look
before i do anything today i have to
just issue a warning
there's going to be a lot of videotaped
footage of the woman that you just saw
there on the program today okay that's
lori lightfoot mayor of chicago and now
insurrectionist we'll get to that in
just a moment we're going to be showing
you videotape of her we're going to be
showing you multiple pictures of her it
ain't pretty let's just get it out right
up top okay i can't sugarcoat this
there's nothing we can do we don't have
enough grease for the lens there's
nothing we could do with photoshop
connor spent seven years at the
photoshop university in greater where
seattle
and uh there was nothing he could do to
make this thing any prettier okay it's a
lot about lori lightfoot today and i
just have to warn you because we had to
watch it and now you have to watch it
too it is a nightmare
but this woman is completely bananas and
my goal today is to destroy her career
because it should be destroyed and she
should not be holding public office
because she's an insurrectionist
far more of an insurrectionist
than donald trump so we're going to get
to
lori lightfoot in a moment but the theme
of today's show is that the hysteria
that the left wants that the media wants
that the democrats want etc etc is being
ramped up to crazy levels and that's all
they got but the silver lining because
you know i'm always going for the silver
lining is i think this is a little bit
too early i think they have shot their
proverbial load a little too early
people and uh they're gonna regret this
because i don't think it's working and i
think they're just showing us exactly
what they are and
for those of us that are sane
for those of us who remain on the same
side of the spectrum we just have to
make sure that they can't control every
waking aspect of your decent humble
life reminder guys on wednesday i head
back out on tour it's already sold out
in brea we got the image there it's
fully sold out it was sold out a couple
days ago they somehow jammed in 70 more
seats those sold out real quick that's
with dennis prager there's about 10
seats left in oxnard with larry elder
and then there's about a dozen seats
left in the other shows san jose with
douglas murray phoenix arizona with
charlie kirk and the next senator from
the great state of arizona blake masters
denver colorado with brian callan and
then the big one uh is june 2nd in
orlando home of disney itself i will be
there uh with florida governor ron
desantis you can get uh whatever tickets
remain at daverubin.com
events and we got a big show for you
real quick though i want to talk to you
about real estate agents i trust you
know buying or selling a home is already
one of the most stressful things you can
do trust me as a guy who just moved and
it can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment and that's a lot of
responsibility and you need an agent who
can take that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
founded by my buddy glenn beck he
started this company himself
they work with the best agents in every
market they do their homework talking to
every agent before inviting them to join
their network and here's a big one they
only work with full-time pros no
part-time or inexperienced agents their
team makes the intro and then follows
you through the buying or selling
process to make sure that you're
satisfied they're partnered with the
blaze and the agents they work with have
a long track record and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
particularly the sunshine state people
the process is simple go to real estate
agents i trust and enter some basic info
that's real estate agents itrust.com
their team will contact you to make an
intro to their preferred agent in your
town and that's it then you sell your
house and you live freely and now back
to me okay so here we go and again i am
just warning you there is going to be
video and pictures of lori lightfoot
okay
it's just how it is the woman's making
news and we have to cover this and i
know it's not plenty and i know it's
early in the morning for some of you
guys and nobody wants to start their day
like this but here we are you know what
i mean it's just it's just what we're
doing so here is a tweet
from last night this is the mayor of
chicago
laurie lightfoot
and there you can see it to my friends
in the lgbtq
plus community the supreme court is
coming for us next this moment has to be
a call to arms and then she followed up
we will not surrender our rights without
a fight
a fight to victory okay lightfoot now
first off we've covered this woman
before she has completely destroyed
chicago i actually want to thank lori
lightfoot because when we did our show
in chicago two weeks ago it was a
matinee show
and i was i actually didn't know that it
was a matinee show we landed in chicago
at about one o'clock i said to my guy
hey i'll see you later tonight i thought
the show was about eight o'clock he's
like what are you talking about we got
the show in about an hour and a half
matinee show
we get there
and the crowd was absolutely incredible
and basically i made lori lightfoot
jokes for two hours it was two hours of
lori lightfoot jokes i wanna credit lori
lightfoot because you are the brunt of
an ongoing joke we actually i had the
entire crowd chant beetlejuice three
times just to see if she would appear on
stage and she actually did there was
smoke coming out of the stage and then
she appeared she was like i love guns
that was it okay so uh look she's
destroyed chicago the gun violence the
the murder rates are insane we'll get to
some of that um and she's she's just an
awful human being who crushed it under
lockdowns and everything else
and now it's not just that she basically
let's throw the tweet up one more time
because i want to get the language here
really right
she said this moment has to be a call
for arms let's just put aside to my
friends in the lgbtq plus community for
a second i don't even know what that
means anymore they jammed these letters
together
it just is completely meaningless it's
not a community uh your sexuality has
nothing to do with the community hope if
you if you still in 2022 think your
sexuality or your gender identity is the
most interesting thing about you you're
boring as [ __ ] basically uh but putting
aside that part this call to arms call
to arms how can we
analyze a call to arms in any other way
than what she literally is saying a call
to arms get your weapons and do
something that is far more of a call for
an insurrection than anything that
donald trump did on january 6 when he
was saying let's peacefully protest
which is exactly what he said that got
him booted from twitter instagram
pinterest and spotify and everywhere
else let's not forget and there are
still people in jail because of what
happened on january 6th a call
to arms because of this well it's not
just that she's calling for violence i i
mean that's that is as short of saying
go murder the people
what else is a call to arms i mean i
just don't know what else it is how else
can we analyze this and she's purposely
doing it because she has democrat
privilege right there's only one
privilege in america in 2022 there's no
white privilege or straight privilege
there's democrat privilege which means
you can question election results stacey
abrams you can call for violence lori
lightfoot uh you can lie about
everything joe biden and the media just
lets you get away with it that is
democrat privilege that's the one big
privilege well she not only is calling
for uh an insurrection and calling for
violence but she also wants to make sure
that chicago will be an oasis
for abortions uh we've got some info
here from fox news democratic chicago
mayor lori lightfoot there she is in all
her glory is vowing that her city will
be a quote oasis for abortions if roe v
wade is overturned on monday lightfoot
announced a justice for all pledge
dedicating five hundred thousand dollars
towards access to abortion care in her
city including transportation and
lodging for women coming in and out of
the state declaring chicago an island of
reproductive freedom and a safe haven in
the midwest not so safe for babies but
okay if you look around chicago we've
got a number of states that have the
so-called trigger laws that would ban
abortion upon the reversal of roe so
we've seen a substantial increase
already lightfoot said and we're
expecting frankly an explosion of new
cases from women in wisconsin missouri
potentially michigan and indiana i think
the list is long and chicago is going to
be an oasis in the midwest and we've got
to be ready so this is very exciting and
it's consistent with lori lightfoot she
has a lot of her own people being killed
by gun violence every weekend how many
people got killed by gun violence in
chicago this weekend can we get the
numbers please
uh
we'll get to the full numbers in a
second i want this weekend can we get
this weekend can we pull that up uh so
she's got a lot of people in her chicago
being killed by gun violence and now she
wants to bring in more people to kill
more babies so that's very exciting but
this is consistent with this psychopath
let's not forget what a tyrant she was
exposed to be
during covet now i've directed
superintendent brown to order all police
districts to give special attention to
these parties
and this is how it's going to be
we will shut you down
we will cite you and if we need to we
will arrest you and we will take you to
jail
period
that is a vile tyrannical human being
who should be in charge of nobody and
seemingly is not very in charge of
herself
by the way 48 people were shot in
chicago this weekend six of them are
dead you're not going to hear lori
lightfoot talking about that and you're
not going to hear about that on msnbc or
in the washington post or the new york
times because it doesn't fit the
narrative because you can figure out the
race of the people doing the shooting
and getting shot and that doesn't help
the race war that they're trying to
start all the time but lori lightfoot
again she's just a terrible person so in
her city people get murdered all the
time now she's saying you can come here
and we'll pay for your abortions now by
the way on the we'll pay for your
abortions thing i don't like the idea of
the state paying for other people's
abortions but if chicago wants if the
people of illinois and in the city of
chicago want legalized abortion i
believe it states rights and if they
want to fund people coming there i'd
prefer that be done by private people
because i don't think the state needs to
be funding it but okay all right these
people elected her and they're given
she's given them what they want a lot of
murder of living people and of fetuses
pretty spectacular but there was lori
lightfoot locking people down
threatening to arrest people and you're
not going to believe what happened just
days after that video when she was going
to arrest you if you go outside well she
got caught at a salon i'm out in the
public eye and you know i'm a i'm i'm a
person who i take my personal hygiene
very seriously as i said i felt like i
needed to
have a haircut i'm not able to do that
myself and so i got a haircut that is
literally the funniest thing i've ever
shown you there is nothing that i can
add to that that will add humor or irony
irony is dead this is a woman who cares
a lot about her personal hygiene this is
a woman who needed a haircut i think we
have some images of her i don't mean to
be a dick about this but this woman who
was threatening just days before to
arrest people for going outside this is
the woman who she cares about her
personal hygiene she needs a haircut
yeah this is i mean she's she's got the
pantene in there and they're with you
with the conditioner and the whole thing
i mean jesus christ this woman's stylist
should be in jail
but
you get it these people they're such
awful human beings they are just
absolutely awful human beings but she
gets worse if you think that
all the people being shot in chicago and
then we're going to murder all the
babies and then we're going to lock you
down but i'm going to get a haircut
because i care about my personal hygiene
you don't use chicago and slob but i do
i'm lori lightfoot here she
you may remember this we covered this a
while back she's also racist
today chicago mayor lightfoot's two-year
anniversary in office to mark that
occasion lifefoot announced she would
only grant one-on-one interviews to
black and brown journalists wgn
political reporter timon bradley sat
down with her to learn more about that
decision
your office says that you invited black
and brown journalists to this round of
interview
why i'm happy to vouch for craig wall
for heather sharon and others
well look i i think in this one day when
we are
looking at the two-year anniversary of
my inauguration as a one-of-a-killer
as a lesbian it's important to me that
diversity is put front and center mayor
lori lightfoot defending her most
unusual decision to only invite black
and brown journalists to her office for
one-on-one interviews
gross she's gross
um but she loves murder and her city is
just a cesspool of murder i think we
have our murder in chicago music for
what i'm about to do
[Music]
we put that together thank you connor
you're getting guacamole today we've got
some info here from nbc 5 on what's
going on in chicago on the murder side
of things although she's not too worried
about it the year of 2021 ended as one
of the most violent on record in chicago
as a rise in the number of shootings
left more people dead than in any single
year and a quarter century according to
statistics released by the police
department on saturday according to the
department 2021 ended with 797 homicides
that was 25 more than were recorded in
2020 299 more than 2019 and the most
since 1996. and there were
3561 shooting incidents in
2021 which is just over 300 more than
they were recorded in 2020 and a
staggering 1415 more shooting incidents
than were recorded in the city of 2000
uh in 2019. so the woman just doesn't do
anything right she is a racist her the
people on her streets are being killed
uh she wants to lock people down but she
really really is into person can i get
the picture one more time and the woman
cares about if we know anything about
this woman she cares about personal
hygiene this is a woman who must she's
in the public eye and must have her hair
conditioned
and their teeth brushed and the face
cream
she's got to have it people it does not
matter
i'm going to puke while i'm doing this
all right
so uh all these people are being shot um
but uh
when they try to call her out on it
she's got excuses do you really believe
that the criticism of you is
99.9
based on the fact that you're a black
woman so you said about 15 things most
of which were wrong so let's let's let's
let's let's let's let's let's just let's
decom let's deconstruct some of that we
didn't have race riots last summer
that's
no no i i no i no
no
no no
no
no you're wrong sir you're wrong
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes there were
race riots they were all over america in
all of the blue cities whether they were
seattle portland los angeles san
francisco
or chicago and they were race riots and
buildings were burned down often owned
by minorities uh in the name of
tolerance and by the way what happened
guys i've been a little out of the loop
last couple days been very busy uh
whatever happened with blm they kind of
disappeared didn't they did they ever do
anything for the black community
whatever happened to those good people
makes me wonder uh one more time let's
just go back to where we started with
this thing this was her tweet last night
this is a sitting mayor of one of the
biggest cities in the united states to
my friends in the lgbt couple just on
the lgbtq thing okay so you got the
lesbians okay and she's a lesbian you
got the gays all right and i got a guy
downstairs who's gay fine uh you got the
bisexuals which you never you ever go to
a gay pride parade come back to me for a
second if you ever go to a gay pride
parade you see these bisexuals you know
they got the parade which i'm not big
into parades in general but there's
always like seven bisexuals and they
look very confused sort of depressed
they're not so thrilled anyway then what
else do we got we got the t's and the t
is the big one now everybody's trans if
you have a penis and you don't think
you're a woman you're not cool right now
and then uh what else we got the q which
i don't even know what that means i
thought that was cue that was bad right
wasn't that didn't mean you were a trump
supporter and you were watching alex
jones and then the plus
nobody knows but the point is the woman
is calling for an insurrection and she
will get away with it she will not be
called by nancy pelosi
joe biden will not
summon her to the white house to say
you're not allowed to call for violence
there will be nothing that happens to
her the only thing that can happen to
her is she must be voted out
bad woman i don't like lori lightfoot
but generally what's happening in the
country right now is that as this roe v
wade briefing has leaked you're going to
see more and more excuses on the left
for violence they will either wink at it
or they will outright endorse it
that's how they're going to do it and
this when i say they i mean the elected
officials and their spokespeople so
whether it's joe biden and then jen saki
or whether it's their cohorts in the
mainstream media so here we've got we
showed you this yesterday but this is
just a quick video of some far left
extremists who threw a molotov cocktail
into a pro-life organization's building
in wisconsin so let's take a look at
that
you know throwing molotov cocktails in
the name of peace and tolerance and
diversity and all that good stuff and
then of course over the weekend we saw
activists show up at churches throughout
the country
we thought this one was interesting
because this one actually is in los
angeles and phoenix my ap here he was
actually baptized in this very church in
los angeles and you can see abortion
activists who showed up to disturb the
catholic mass
hey you get off of him
you are not you are not attacking
anybody
[Music]
respect us
i understand
strange they never try it in mosques
isn't that weird um now there's of
course a gajillion levels of irony there
and ridiculousness first off they're
doing this in california california is
going to be the abortion capital of the
world gavin newsom will gladly rip the
babies out himself and spew their blood
all over his face just like was that too
much too much imagery that was a bit
much oh no you like that one okay i
thought michael has given me one of
these that's usually dave you've gone
too far but you were actually giving me
one of these um so the fact that they're
doing this in california is ridiculous
that's number one number two
religious institutions are allowed to
have their own beliefs on things the
catholic church
or a jewish temple or a muslim mosque
etc are allowed to have their own
religious beliefs when it comes to
marriage abortion or a whole series of
other issues you do not have a right to
come in and burst into their services
and use your free speech to impinge on
their free speech that is that is the
negotiation we have with speech right uh
and it's strange because you never see
the pro-lifers just bursting into
abortion clinics uh you know it's
happened over the years right years ago
there would every now and again be a
crazy person who would do something to
an abortion doctor or clinic and of
course it should be condemned fully
absolutely condemned fully but the point
is that you're not going to see anybody
on the left condemn any of this and then
we just got three uh images of just some
of the stuff that are being written on
churches and on schools and buildings if
abortions aren't safe then you are in
either
tolerance that's nice my body my choice
that's with the satan symbol what's
satan been up to i feel like he's been
very busy
and apparently doing graffiti and then
my body my choice and that's of course
on sacred heart of mary church right
there and what's interesting
about the my body my choice people of
course are these are the exact same
people
almost without exception who were
demanding that you get injected
right they didn't care about your body
right they wanted me to get ejected with
something that i chose not to get
injected with and i'm very proud that i
stood up against the machine and did not
get injected with it and i meet all
sorts of people who stood up and did not
get injected but they really wanted
control over our bodies they were demand
no one's demanding anyone get an
abortion but they were demanding that we
get injected with something to either
keep our job or be a respected member of
society so these are obviously
hypocrites usually buffoons and morons
and not very good people who have any
understanding of what a exchange would
be like in a free society uh but the
issue also is that the left and the
media are all framing this in one way
they are framing this because they're
intentionally confusing a bunch of
really um not bright unfortunately
because our education system is not very
good a bunch of not bright people about
what's going on here i said it the first
day that this thing happened that i bet
you that something like 30 of america
and now i would say it's probably even
closer to 50 percent think that roe v
wade being reversed makes abortion
illegal it does not as you know 30
states are going to still have abortion
and i and it might be even 40 states
will have some version of abortion we're
going to have some something like
florida 15 weeks which is a moderate
that is a freaking moderate moderate
position whether you like it or not that
is called a compromise right you're not
giving the pro-lifers everything they
want you're not giving the pro-choice
people everything they want and that's
what's happening right here in the
radical right-wing state of florida but
they are framing everything as
everything must be done by the federal
government because at the end of the day
leftists do not like choice they pretend
they call themselves pro-choice but they
don't like choice they like a decision
to be made by the machine above you
and in this case the government and then
that decision should dictate how you
live
ironically the choice part if there is
if there is someone that is for choice
here choice would be pushing it all back
to the states and ironically beto
o'rourke who is a furry who ran for uh
when he ran for senator in texas a
couple years ago and ted cruz just beat
him thank god but now he's running for
governor of texas
he accidentally
made the very argument that i'm saying
right now
he's telling people in speeches that
americans should decide you should
decide but he doesn't even realize the
argument he's making listen to this
so my question actually goes to the
first amendment how are you going to
keep
church and state separated because as we
clearly know there's a direct tie
between abortion bans and church
thank you so much for being here and for
asking that great question
um it's got to be the people right it's
got to be the people who decide the
outcomes of these issues
it's got to be the people it's got to be
the people but that's not what he thinks
he's saying he's right it's got to be
the people we are a government for and
of the people right
that's what we are so if you are leaving
it to the people
beto o'rourke then you would say the
people of texas can make a certain
decision
by the way the people of texas have made
a certain decision it's six weeks now
that seems too extreme for me but i am
not a texan and if i
lived in texas and i and that was the
number one driver
of my life was abortion rights i would
leave texas
and i'm not just saying that i'm someone
who left california because i did not
want to live in the dystopian lunacy of
california right that is the beautiful
thing you have the foot vote you have
the ability to pick up and go you
everyone really better understand this
like this is such an amazing thing that
we have in the united states that most
countries do not have where we have
vastly different laws we have the
machinery capable of allowing for choice
but the choice is up to the states we
are the united states we may not be that
united anymore and maybe that's okay but
beto o'rourke is saying leave it up to
the people except that's not really what
he thinks he's saying he thinks he's
saying leave it up to the people meaning
uh the supreme court has just decided
that everyone should have abortions uh
and most of the left thinks this i think
most of them think that this is an
outright ban and why do they think it
well you've got people like white house
spokeswoman outgoing i can now call her
outgoing white house spokeswoman jen
sachi and she's telling us you know the
the abortion ban could be coming
nationwide thank you on abortion
republican leader mitch mcconnell has
said that a national ban on abortion
could be possible depending on the votes
without court intervention just how at
risk does the administration believe the
u.s is to completely outlaw abortion
i think we're at serious risk
no
but we're not this has nothing to do
with banning abortion
it just kicks it back to the states
where it always was before 1973.
and again i say this is someone who's
begrudgingly pro-choice
you've got to have principles even when
it's hard to have principles but they
want fear they want you to think that
now they're going to come for everyone's
abortions but again gavin newsom is
going to have an abortion park
in
california and that is where they will
abort all the babies and then nancy
pelosi will drink all the blood and all
of that stuff i realize that i've
mentioned california a few times here
and i have to put some money in the jar
so there you go we will either get
someone out of california that was the
original intent of this jar or i will
put all the money towards getting rid of
a democrat from florida that seems like
a better use of money but we'll see what
happens
um
the democrats seemingly though they want
total control over everything that's
really what this is all about we can we
can sort of frame these arguments
in this is about abortion but really
what this is about is do you want one
government to tell us all how to live or
not and the thing is the reason they
want us focusing on this and i think the
reason the leak came out and by the way
why aren't we talking about the leaker
notice nobody's looking into it what who
is this leaker how did this happen was
it a hack was it one of the justices
that leaked it was it one of their
clerks we need to know like if there's
any hope that we can trust our
institutions and the very processes that
that exist so that we can have a
functional democracy we better find out
who it is but nobody's even looking into
it because the left's getting everything
they want right so the media is not
going to look into it because it will
make them look bad you know meaning
it'll make the the democrats look bad
obviously um but all of this goes to
what i said a couple days ago which is
right now we had a couple big wins right
we had a big win related to elon getting
twitter that's good we had a big win
related to
uh justice mizell knocking down the mask
mandate on planes we had big wins
related to
desantis fighting the crt stuff here in
florida there was a bunch of big wins
and not only were there big wins but
then there were all these signs that the
democrats are just screwing up
everything with supply chain and
inflation okay fine you guys all get it
but now our eyes off the ball and i'm
gonna do my best to make sure our eye
does not stay off the ball they want us
in a constant shell game never figuring
out what is real and always not thinking
about the right thing so let's go back
and and talk about some of the things
that are not working that they don't
have us talking about right now well how
about inflation saki doesn't think any
of us knew that this was going to happen
we know if we look at the recent
inflation data a large depending on
which data you look at two-thirds to
even 70 percent of inflation data is a
result of energy prices a large part of
that is the result and and chairman
powell has spoken to this and secretary
um secretary yellen has also spoken to
this as a result of president putin's
invasion of ukraine and the impact on
the
global energy markets those are all
steps and impacts that i don't think
anyone could have predicted a year ago
nonsense everyone could have predicted
it number one number two it's also a lie
like everyone could have predicted
inflation obviously but it's a lie that
this is all because of putin first off
if putin can just decide when we have
inflation or when we don't have
inflation or if any foreign leader can
decide that then then our entire foreign
policy is upside down now now that may
be except we know that this isn't
because of putin right first off prices
were going up we've covered this many
times gas prices were already up over a
dollar
before the the invasion of ukraine and
do you think if you endlessly print
money
do you think if you just let's say you
have a certain amount of money and then
you have a machine over there and the
machine just starts printing all of this
money and you start giving it to
everybody do you think that the amount
that you had first might start dropping
well that's what they've been doing they
endlessly print
money but don't worry guys joe biden's
here to save us he's very concerned
my top priority is fighting inflation
and lowering prices for families and
things they need today's announcement is
going to give millions of families a
little more a little more breathing room
to help them pay their bills
you know we work with democrats and
republicans and business and nonprofits
to make this happen
and we're going to keep working to fight
inflation and lower cost of to all
american families for a lot of other
things as well
he's going to keep working i mean this
is the same guy let's not forget who
july 4th of last year saved you 16
to remember not 16 that would be pretty
good saved you 16 cents
16 cents on your july 4th barbecue and
they even put up an image from the
official potus account remember that one
16 cents hey biden i know you're not in
charge and you're just pretending but if
you really wanted people to have more
money in their pocket how about tax cuts
for everybody how about a 25 tax cut
across the board right now but you won't
do that will ya how about we just take
less money from you people in the first
place not gonna do that because that's
not what this really about you can't
pull the wool over my eyes man uh but
now on a less joking side there are huge
problems that are developing because of
this because we can talk about oh that
you can't get a car right now and you
can't get you know a chair from
creighton barrel or whatever else now we
have a nationwide baby formula shortage
this is real stuff
empty shelves this is really scary and
worried parent a couple stores we've
been in we have not had it we've had to
go to the next location
they are looking for baby formula and
not finding it at least not easily i
myself am down to one can of formula
at the end of april nearly 40 percent of
popular baby formulas were sold out
across the u.s that's up from 31 percent
two weeks before the shortage is getting
worse
this
is a pain about to find baby formula
like many things has been affected by
supply chain issues okay so this is
serious stuff i can tell you as someone
we're about to have two babies and we've
been ordering baby food already we've
been ordering formula already um our
first baby's not due till august second
one's not till october and that just
puts more strain because more people are
looking for this stuff but this is not
because of putin this is because of the
ridiculous buffoons who are in charge of
our government you cannot excuse all of
this stuff but they excuse it they
always figure out an excuse because they
lie meaning the administration lies and
then they get the ridiculous people
of places like msnbc to confuse us about
what's going on as well
video
i i still think
one of the fundamental things that
happened here in covin is that americans
normally spend most of their money on
services and because of covet they
haven't been able to spend money on
services and they went out and the
demand for tvs and pelotons and exercise
equipment and houses and a whole bunch
of physical goods
broke the supply chain because it's
never been higher
it's not their fault people it's you
freaks for getting your pelotons and
your tvs you just wanted too much stuff
we've never had a problem with that in
the united states before capitalism has
always basically provided for everybody
and the whole thing about america was oh
but everyone has too much stuff and you
know there's too many tvs and too many
vcrs
but now it's not that they've destroyed
the entire thing by closing businesses
and raising taxes and forcing people out
of work and all of those things it's
that you schmucks you just want too many
tvs god these people are terrible and
speaking of terrible people
elizabeth warren who is a crazy
socialist from uh massachusetts she went
on the
the view i have to do we have the we
have there we go content advisory
warning what you're about to see is pure
[ __ ] elizabeth warren went on the
view and uh we showed you this video
yesterday uh of lindsey granger she is a
guest host so i guess she's testing out
to see if she can be the conservative on
the view because obviously you have to
have four liberals and one conservative
because that's a fair makeup of america
and lindsay granger who's spectacular
and i want to get her on the show she
just wrecked sonny hostin yesterday when
sunny hostin basically said you know you
can't have black republicans like it's
just it's just so awful and racist by
sonny hostin and joy and the rest of the
clowns but anyway elizabeth warren was
on yesterday and uh talking about
student loan debt and lindsey granger
made a great point hey what about all
the people that have worked and busted
their butts to pay off their student
loans
i mean you've been fiercely advocating
for the president to cancel student loan
debts but really only 13
of americans even have federal student
loan debt so is this really the best way
to reach most voters and also what do
you say to someone like me who worked
two jobs for a decade to pay off all
their student loans just finished where
do i sign up for reimbursement
so let's start out
with
who has student loans today
about 40 percent of the folks with
student loans don't have a college
diploma
they're folks who tried yeah they're
folks who tried and life happened
pregnancies uh they were already working
two jobs and lost one of them uh mom got
sick family had to move somewhere else
and now they earn what a high school
grad earns and they're trying to pay off
college-level debt and it is crushing
their bones
okay first off could someone possibly
come off as more inauthentic right like
so in other folks the folks the folks
she didn't answer the question at all
the question was hey what about someone
like me who busted my butt who worked
two jobs to pay off my debt are you
going to take care of me you're going to
you're going to pay me back for all that
and then what what elizabeth warren does
there is standard leftist 101 she makes
up sort of an imaginary situation about
these people and and she she's playing
to your emotion now we might be able to
figure out some ways to help some of
those people i'm actually not completely
against some of that but i would also
say that maybe not everyone has to go to
four-year universities maybe you should
go to trade school maybe you should
learn things outside of the university
system and give a little power back to
yourself and not go a hundred thousand
dollars into debt to have a four-year
degree in lesbian archery to then not
have any skills and also been taught
that america's evil the entire time and
everything else so elizabeth warren has
no answers for anything other than we
the government want more of your money
to pay off other people's problems and
it's just [ __ ] and nobody nobody
buys it anymore and that's why she comes
off as so what is elizabeth warren
always she always comes off as the sort
of librarian who is holier than now and
she really cares about everybody more
than you by the way her kids even though
she's a big proponent of public schools
her kids went to private school she also
pretended to be a native american to get
a job i mean these are horrible people
but what do they have they have their
holier-than-thou attitude and these
folks and i really care about these
folks or they have their crazy outrage
which remember we had the video the
other day she's very angry about
abortion she wants as many dead babies
as possible the they've become the party
of tyrants and big government losers so
the rest of us have to be the party and
i don't mean political party we should
be an actual party with music and
drinking and fun and happiness and
smiles of free people that agree that
humanity is a little bit messy or all
we're going to do is create the
conditions
so that you might have a chance to live
the life that you want to live and with
that note uh you may remember the orange
man well he's been giving speeches again
and he's not he's not taking it it seems
pretty obvious to me he's about to jump
back in and uh and go for it like he's
gonna get back into the election that's
what everyone's saying and it certainly
sounds like it and he's calling them out
for exactly what they are
democrats are the party of crime
the party of chaos and the party of
death they are whether you
hate saying it or like saying it they're
the party of death republicans are the
party of law order and life
and you know what else the republicans
are
they're the party of the american dream
they really are they're the party of the
american dream which is being taken away
from you
if you want to make our country safer
for
violent criminals vote for the radical
democrats if you want to make it safer
for your family your children and for
law
abiding americans you must vote
for republicans you must
you know it's interesting he's sort of
taken a nod from something that i say
all the time there which is that you
don't have to be a republican but you
can't be a democrat that's kind of what
he's saying there at the end you have to
vote for republicans right now it just
is that's sort of a depressing situation
because it's not like republicans are so
great it's not like i've got a picture
of mitch mcconnell above my bed it's not
that
mitt romney i don't have a picture of
mitch mcconnell over my bed do i unless
you guys are punching me it's not that
uh mitt romney is so great it's not that
liz cheney is so great some of these
people are quite horrible actually but
they are better than the democrats at
least there is a basic understanding of
what law and order in this country is
all about uh we got a
great cold clothes for you so hang tight
for that in just a second
margo over at
rubenreport.locals.com we have a live
chat running during the show margot says
are you sure laurie is human dave
unless you know something i don't know i
suppose she is human but she should not
be in charge of chicago like at the who
who in their right mind i just can't
imagine can we find a laurie lightfoot
supporter and get them on the show like
i'm a lorry i want someone with like a
i'm a proud lori lightfoot there she is
that she cares about hygiene right
personal hygiene sure there's a pandemic
but i have to get my hair cut i do you
know what it was like for look i really
care about my hair okay there's a lot of
hairspray there i got a haircut
yesterday um for those two three months
where nobody could get a haircut my hair
was flat i wasn't thrilled with it the
guys had to often give me signals
michael had a piece of paper sometimes
that he would show me while i was live
streaming to say fix the hair because it
was kind of going this way and i was
falling over a little bit
but i couldn't break the law well
actually i
did well okay next question i did i did
what i had to do so i guess i am a
little more like lorelei but she cares
about hygiene that's a woman she brushes
her teeth seven times a day okay
insanity amy says it's not just chicago
my friend is in far southeast suburb
mukena
and just posted on twitter how she's
sick of not being able to go anywhere
even out to her car
because crime is so horrible you know
i'll tell you something interesting
about that
so since i've moved to florida we
actually go out again and we go to
restaurants and i went to a restaurant
last night and florida this i'm in miami
area and wherever i've gone it's
jam-packed wherever you go every
restaurant is jam-packed you gotta make
reservations you gotta wait it's great
and people are out and about so we go
out the other night david's um mom
and uh and boyfriend were in town and we
go out for dinner and it's uh this was
on sunday night actually and we're out
in a really cool part of town and it's
late night like 11 or 11 30 or so and
we're just wandering around we had
dinner we're getting some ice cream and
there's people everywhere and we we got
into the uber and david said to me
did you notice that there were no shady
people out there like there were no
crazy homeless people there was no one
begging for money there was no one that
you felt like you were gonna get punched
or have your bag stolen or have your
watch ripped off or anything else like
there is a culture of goodness here and
that these the leftists have destroyed
these cities and it's not just the
obvious things it's not just the obvious
problem with homelessness and the
obvious drug problem it's that then it
creates a culture where people when
you're out on the streets you forget
that you can be in a place that's just
happy and run right and that the police
are making sure everything's in charge
and everything's run right and
everything else and it starts with it's
well it starts with us but then it it
goes to voting in the right people
casey says defund the police and
depopulate the city are you talking
about chicago defund the police and deep
well maybe depopulate i'm not exactly
sure what you mean there depopulate the
city first i suppose get the same people
out of chicago let them have the rest of
chicago and uh yeah and then go from
there defund the police and depopulate
the city not totally following it
am i missing something there we want to
fund the police don't we
oh it's an oasis of abortion i'm still
not fully understanding it casey i'm
going to follow up with you at the
locals community because every comment
is important to me uh guys reminder i'm
heading back out on the road tomorrow uh
i'm in brea it's already sold out but
then on uh on what days tomorrow
tomorrow's wednesday so on thursday i'm
in oxnard with larry elder then i'm in
san jose with douglas murray then in
phoenix with charlie kirk and blake
masters then denver with brian callan
and then june 2nd back in the free state
of florida with governor ron desantis
you can get tickets at daverman.com
events
and as if you have not had enough
of miss laurie lightfoot we've got more
of that video that we opened up with and
uh i feel
i owe you an apology in some ways for
today's show i've enjoyed it i think
there were a lot of good laughs and good
times but we she just one more time let
me see the picture of her one more time
this woman this is hygiene 101 okay
she's allowed to break her copic laws
she's allowed to go out there and go see
her stylist because she needs it she
needs it
that's a woman who i agree with her that
is a woman who needs a stylist goodbye
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so guess what we're here to talk about
today
good afternoon everyone